اكثر من سبعين ساعه تفصلنا عن معرفه من
سيحكم تركيا والرئيس التركي اردوغان يواجه
اصعب معركه انتخابيه بعدما وحدت ست احزاب
معارضه قواها لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه ضده وكشف هنا استطلاع للراي
نقلته رويترز ان زعيم المعارضه
يتقدم على منافسه اردوغان
كما نشاهد هنا رجب اردوغان بثلاثه واربعين
بالمئه
49,3
بينما طبعا كما شاهدنا هنا
49.3% في حال لم يتمكن المرشحه الرئاسي من
الحصول على اكثر من نصف الاصوات في الرابع
عشر من مايو سوف تعاد الانتخابات بعد
اسبوعين من تاريخ هذا الاحد وكي يتمكن اي
حزب من دخول البرلمان ذي ال600 مقعد يتعين
عليه الحصول على 7% من اصوات النخيبين او
ان يكون جزءا من تحالف يحصل على هذه
النسبه اما الناخبون الاتراك فسيصوتون
للقوائم الحزبيه وليس للمرشحين طبعا بموجب
نظام التمثيل النسبي الموجود الان في
تركيا ومن ثم فان عدد المقاعد تحدده
الاصوات التي تمنح لكل حزب وليس للتحالفات
وفقا ايضا للقانون التركي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات